Ya ben Doktor Levent Köstem 41 yıllık
hekimim Hekim lafını daha çok seviyorum
doktordayız biraz daha laboratuvar
anlamında çıkıyor Her kim deyince daha
Lokman daha insancıl bir da o yüzden
hekim de seni çok seviyorum 37 yıllık da
ortopedi uzmanıyım niye böyle çıktığımda
söyleyeyim bu gençler çok muhteşem
muhteşem toplantı düzenlemişler sizin
gibi gençlerle benim gibi Dünya Sağlık
Örgütü'ne göre artık yaşlılık sınıfına
girmeye başlamış bir insanı buluşturduğu
için ben kendisine teşekkür ediyorum ve
bana böyle bir hediye Verdiler ben
burada bir çok renk var aslında basıncı
değişik renklere giriyor değişik bir şey
ama ben bu ülkede Yaşar Kemal Biraz önce
söylemiş ya arkadaşımız anlattı Dedi ki
bu ülkede kadın
o başka
o çocuk başka ha ağaç başka
bir sokak hayvanı olmayacaksınız dedi
ama bir şeyi unutmuş Yaşar Kemal yüzde
on iki buçuğu Bu ülkenin engelli engelli
unutmuş Yaşar Kemal engelleri
uluslararası rengi Aslında kırmızı bu
birazcık o rengi andırdığı için ben
burada hepimizin engelleri biraz daha
anlamamız onlarla ilgili duygu
birlikleri yapmamız için bu rengi buraya
getirdim Kendinize çok teşekkür ediyorum
buraya koymam söylediler bere Evet Ben
hayatım boyunca sınırlamalara çok ve hep
karşı çıktım o yüzden de oradan resmi
üzüldüm bana bırak bak sakın 10-15
dakika geçme en fazla üç dakika
geçebilirsin bile kırmızı bir halı var
orada sakın geçme kırmızı çizgilerinden
beni açmaya çalıştım onu o gün
açmayacağım Çünkü çekim varmış
ya ben bugün size Gülcemal vapuru bu
cayır 5.18 Treni
bu çocukluk hayallerimiz zeytin
ağaçlarını urla'yı ve doğayı Anlatmaya
çalışacağım 15 dakikaya sarsa Ben
Gülcemal vapuru Aslında bizim Buca ve
bizim çocukluğumuzda 15-20 bin nüfuslu
bir yerde yaylacıların haricinde hemen
hemen hepsi bu Gülcemal vapuruyla
zorunlu Göçe Balkanlar'dan tabi tutulmuş
insanlardı Benim büyük bölümde dramanın
bir Seçen köyünden buraya zorunlu Göçe
tabi tutulmuş ve bu insanların hepsi bu
Gülcemal vapuru ile getirilmiş Alsancak
ona atılmış ve 1956'da yıkılan Sarıkışla
koymuş hep sordu bitlenmiş ler ve sonra
Bizimkileri akrabalarla birlikte Buca
yerleştirmiş t21c yerleştir Sen bizim
çocukluğumuzda Buca Cennet gibi bir yer
demişti Burası Buca çocukluğumuzda
bundan da çok da farklı değil mi Özkan
aşağı yukarı böyleydi Özkan da bizim
ve ayrıca derneğin başkanı O da aramızda
Buca her tarafı Bağlık bahçelik
Zeytinlik inanılmaz bir yer yani hep
insanlar öbür tarafta cenneti düşünüyor
ya asla Biz Doğduğumuzda cennete doğmuş
tuk şirinyerin öbür adını biliyor
musunuz Aslında ilk adı ne olduğunu para
istiyor Cennet Aslında öyle bir yerde
ama biz maalesef becerebildik bir şeyi
Buca gibi cennet gibi bir yere Şirinyer
gibi cennet göre insan İyi de mahvettik
ve hakikaten Şehircilik anlamında
literatüre geçecek berbat bir yer haline
getirdik Buca'da doğdum büyüdüm
ilkokulu-ortaokulu Buca'da oturdum sonra
burada ya seni öğrencisin Siz Atatürk
sesini verelim listesine verdiler bile
atomik sesini bize hepimizi bizim
mühendis olmak üzere yetiştirdiler
İstanbul tekniği kazandım ben gittim
İstanbul tekniği Kağıt dedim ben bunu
okuyamam ekonomik olarak mümkün değil
kaldıramam Ailemde kaldıramaz bunu
mahallemizde de Abdurrahim amca berber
Afrin
sen böyle beni bütün mahallenin şehri
ısrar söylüyor ya doktor olman lazım
işte bak bu SSK Hastanesi kimse
ilgilenmiyor sen diye ben tıp
fakültesine girdim ama bir sınıfın
ortalığı tekrar mühendisi olayım diye
düşünürken o dönemde Atatürk sesi çok
fazla Tıp Fakültesi öğrenci sokuyordu
Eve baktım bütün öğrenciler Atatürk
sesinden Anadolu Lisesi'nde ne zorunda
kaldık iki sınıfa geldi ki sınıfta ve
kanal buraya girdik kadar odas8 öğrenci
Bir zamanlar öyledir bilgisayardan kadar
dersi yapılmıyordu hepimize kadar
veriyordu 8 kişiyle bir kadar veriyordu
ve biz ve kimse söylemedi Ben kadar da
yapmaya başladım ve sonra Jerry almaya
bak karar verdim 3 sınırsız ortopedi
olmuyor ortopedi uzmanı olmaya karar
verdim sonra ortopedi uzmanı oldum 1982
yılında Ben 40 yıllık hekimim 37 yılda
ortopedi uzmanı yapıyorum ama hep spor
cerrahisini Hayal ettiğimiz bu cerraha
olmaya çalıştım ben
o ölmek kim olursa alt alıyım ve ve 25
yılda Altay'ın takım doktorunu yaptım
uzun yıllar milli takımda görev yaptım
sağlar da çalıştım sürekli çocuklarımı
nasıl büyüdüğünü Görmedim yani bir hafta
İzmir bir hafta deplasman böyle gidip
geldik o dönemde inovasyonu her zaman
takip ettim o dönemde de asla Biz tıpta
girdiğimizde İnovasyon en iyi
bölümleriyle karşılar yani Mesela bizim
dönemimizde önce biz tıp fakültesine
girdiğinizde emar yoktu tomografi yoktu
Usta son Yok daha birçok şey yok daha
biz bunları gördük ve bu İmam Hatip
girişimleri adapte oldu Sonra ben
ortopedi de kongre gitmeye başladım ve
kongre gitmeye başlayacağım üç tanesi
arthroscopy gibi şeyle karşılaştım ya bu
adamları anlatıyorum 28 ile ilgilenmiyor
ya küçücük deliklerden giriyorsun bir
şeyler yapmaya çalışıyorsun Ben çok
meraklandım ve bir Alman bir kurs vardı
Antalya'da okursa bir şeyler yapmaya
çalışacağım hoca geldi Hadi sen
ne varsa bakıyorsun Sen devam et bana
dedi Ben daha sonra Aksu bir yer almayı
kafaya koydum yani eklemin kapalı olarak
endoskopik bir optikle görülüp ve
cerrahisi yapılması işlemi ben bu
konunun Türkiye'deki öncülerinden biri
oldum ama o artroskopik cerrahi bana çok
şey kattı Bizim ailemiz normal Bucalı
bir aile işte ve Ben hatta eğitime
giderken Almanya otobüs uçak bileti
almadım otobüsle gitmek zorunda kaldım
Almanya'ya gittim geldim ve o dönemde
artroskopik cerrahi hemen İstanbul'da
Ömer Taşer var Bir de Ankaralı Mahmut
dedim doğru alabiliriz de ben varım Ve
sonunda doğal olarak Aslan çok oldu ve
aslan çok olunca da 353 hızlanmaya
başladım Doktorlar Para kazanacağız ne
yapar
Yok yok bina alır kiraya verir araba
alır değiştirir ya da ya kalır gezerdi
Ben tarla aldım her aldım tarlada zeytin
dikmeye başladım aldım Zeytinlik
Zeytinlik Team bye arkadaşlar Oğlum sen
manyak mısın dediler Evet manyak dedim
İbrahim aşağıya kadar çocuklar
bu daha çocuklar dönüş buraya
katılanların şehri Biraz önce sordum
18-55 yaş arası ymış profil ve ben ona
göre biraz daha büyüğüm ve Ben aşağıya
kır onbirbin zeytin ağaç diktim ve
bunları büyük şu anda başında oldum
Teşekkür ederim diktiğim ağaç sayısı
zeytinlerin haricinde 12 bin 500
civarında bulmuştur ve Ben buraları
gördüğünüz gibi tarla aldım Hani
projesini satan adam var ya şimdi ona
benzettim demeyin ama ben de mercedesini
sattım Param yoktu Gittim Mercedes
satarak paraya denk değiştirdim not alan
köyünde bir oğlan var bizim Altay'ın alt
yapısı böyle çok yetenekli olan neyse
işte abi bizim köye gelmedi bugün gittik
Emrah'ı bir yılbaşı hiç unutmuyorum
Yarın ben bir Zeytinlik almak için
çocukluğumdan beri hayalim Ne yapayım
dedim amcam bir yer satıyordu deniz 18/1
aldık aşağısına aldık üstüne aldık
Bilmem Ne derken Her aldım yeri zeytin
diktim eve aldığımda
Bu şekilde bir müddet sonra organik
sertifikalı ve ben bir müddet sonra
organik tarımcıoğlu ne organik zeytin
diktikten sonra da yarın bunu bir
kültürü olması lazım ve çocukluğumdan
beri de böyle pulcular meraklıyım Yani
her şey biriktirir böyle bir yapım var
benim yani biraz şey yapıyor Hanım
kızıyor Gerçi her şey biriktiriyorsun
diye amcam böyle dedim sonunda ben bir
müze kurmaya niyetlendim sordum bizim
orada satılık yerler var mıdır 923
kalmış geriye sonra bir tane bina
satılıyormuş uzun köyde uzun kilo binayı
Aslında icradan Satılmış ama adamcağızı
buldum Eskişehir'e kaldım Çünkü bir şey
Alman oruçluk getireceğim satın aldım
beş yıl oranı taksitleri ödedim ben her
yaptım şimdi Çocuklar kendi
kazançlarında yaptım
bu ve sonra da güven bakır hocayı buldum
alakalı İplikçi buldum nasıl müze kurmam
lazım dedim onlar bana Nasıl güzel
kurmam gerektiğini Ben de okuyorum da
bir yurt dışında çok fazla gittim gezdim
müzenin hayallerini kurmaya başladım ve
kamyonet aldım Bu sırada bir insan
kamyonet aldım tarz sındırgıdan Muğla'ya
kadar bütün her yere hastalığı mahvettin
çok kötü Aslan vardı benim ve oralardan
çok malzeme topladım ve sonunda
bu müze kurma aşamasına geldim Güven
bakın Hoca rahmetli oldu müthiş bir
adamda urlar kazı başkanıydı ya Doktor
dedi bu iş o kadar kolay değil kardeşim
dedi Yani sen kıracaksın bak bir
kaportacısı olsun ama yani ne yapacaksın
Evet hocam bulamazsam aldıklarımı
hurdacıya satarım ya da antikacı satarım
binayı kiraya veririm Ne yapalım olacak
olan bu ama bir güç verdi çocuklar ben
çalıştım çabaladım hayallerimi Çünkü
gerçekleştirmek için çocukluğumdan beri
Bir hayalim vardı bir zeytinliği musun
istiyordum ve doğaya katkı sunmak
istiyorum binlerce ağaç diktim eşim bu
konuya çok meraklı Çocuklarım çok
meraklı kızım da burada sonunda işte
buraları bir hale getirdik bunları
bakmaya başladı bunu hepsi arada gitmedi
zaman beni özlüyorlar beni görmek
istiyorlar ben dolaşıyorum Onların
aralarında geçen birisi paylaşmış diyor
ki yangında diyor işte ağaçlar ve
canlılar öldürüyor ya kardeşim Hepsi
canlılığı bunlar kendi Aralarında
konuşuyorlar zeytin ağacı öyle bir
en sonunda ben bir müze kurmaya
niyetlendikten sonra müzenin bütün
malzemeleri toplamaya başladım bütün
Ege'den topladım Ondan sonra çok zorlu
bir süreç başladı bu ülkede iyi bir şey
yapıyorsan başına Her şey gelebiliyor
Şuraya geçmem lazım yani ediyorum
sonunda izin aldım küçük senenin sonunda
6 bin 500 metrekare kapalı alanda bir
müze kurmaya niyetlendim ama müze
kıracağım ama yani eski klasik hücreler
içine koydu şeyleri koy ondan sonra bunu
da açtık gelsin geçsin böyle bir şey
değil müzecilik eğitim olayı insanlara
Çocuklar özellikle eğitimi vermemiz ve
müziğini çıkıyorum çocuklar için
kuruyorum gelecek için kuruyorum Biz
müzeyi bir zeytinyağı Teknoloji Müzesi
kurmaya çalıştık ailemle birlikte Burada
bir tane Vakıf kurdu Kösem kültür
eğitimi müzecilik Vakfı eşim kızım ve
oğlumla birlikte tabi insana bu
konularda ashe destek olmaz hiçbir şey
bağımsız sınıfta kalırsın onu da
söyleyeyim Eşim çok büyük destek oldu
bu müziği kurmaya başardık müjdenin
içine dedi ki biz o zaman yeni müzeci
kavramında mutlaka bunun içinde satış
dükkanda olması lazım Neden Çünkü
çevrenin ürünlerini kooperatifle sharrac
bir yerde satmamız gerekiyor Bunları
şimdi köyleri anlatmaya çalışıyorum Onun
haricinde başka Şeref var olması lazım
doğal bizim Michelin yıldızlı değil de
benim Seher hanımın salataların da ben
annemi Seher Benim adım salatadan Ahmet
sonra köfteleri Ben orada yapmak
istiyorum bana ne çok da benim için
önemli değil ben bunları insanlara
anlatmaya çalışıyorum içine çok model
zeytinyağı fabrikası kurmam gerekiyor
öyle olması lazım ki benim
ameliyathanede çalıştığım kadar iyidir
Temizlikte olsun sonra çocuklar için
bilim sanat tasarım merkezi kurmam lazım
dedim içine 8 metrekare içinde çok iyi
ahşap atölyesi olan beceri Salonu olan
kendi kafesi olan yeni dönem bahçesi
olan bir çocuklarla ilgili bilim sanat
tasarım merkezi kurduk ve gelenler
nerede kalacaksın çocuk
de bir tane butik otel kurmaya çalıştık
böyle bir yaratık bunları kurmak o kadar
kolay değil yani ben şu anda bile 65
yaşındayım Sabah altı buçukta evimden
çıkıyorum ben altmış yaşına cerrahı
bırakırım diye düşünüyorum ama bu insanı
bir motivasyon veriyor özellikle
çocuklar için ben bu motivasyonla
çalışıyorum Sabahları 6'da çıkıyorum gc9
Onu da eve geliyorum sürekli çalışıyorum
cumartesi pazar da müzede çalışmaya
çalışıyorum ve sonunda Biz müzeyi
gerçekleştirmeye çalıştık ve belli
aşamalara geldik tabii müze deyince
teşvik almak istiyorsun Ben üç kere
İskele başvurdum 3'ünde destekleme değer
bulunmadılar ve reddettiler bizim
üzerimize ve Başbakanlık tanıtma fonu da
başvuru dediler bana başvurdum oranları
reddettiler sonra bugün şu anda bir
ilimizde bağlı olan kaymakamımız var
dedi ki Başaran Ulusoy gelecek dedi kim
dedim o ben çok bilmiyorum
Ya kardeşim biliyordum Ama başarılı
söylüyordum şeymiş bu tür sabah başkanı
bir Ben onunla konuştum dedi sizin
yüzeye destek olabilir dedi O ne kadar
güzel dünya bir şeyler verecek herhalde
Bizimki ben de müziği bitireceğim çünkü
destek arıyorum Bu konularla ilgili Yok
hiç bütün açalım kapılar kapanıyor Neyse
geldi ve beni büyük Üniversitesi böyle
işte bu dünyaya geldi bu halindeyken
bizim bu ilk aldığımızda bina böyleydi
Ben aldığım şeyleri için attım senelerce
sonra gezdi dolaştı dolaştı dolaştı en
sonda şu en sonda gördüğünüz bir şey var
ya bakın direkten sonrakiler oraya
gelmişti arabayla oraya kadar o camı
siyah Mercedes Mercedes'in kapısını
açtığı döndü bana aferin Tamam şimdi
Başaran bey bana
ne diyecek ya Levent Bey sana 300 bin
500 bin veriyoruz şunları yap diyecektim
ben de beni bekliyorum Öyle açıldı
bekliyorum hocam ya dedi sana belli
rapor almak lazım dedi bana
bu üstü Ben bozuluyor mı Ne yapayım
anlayamadım ve onun sonunda tabi peki
dedim Ne yapalım adam arabasına
gittiğini destek arayışların sürdüğü Ama
bu sırada hepsinde kendi çalışmama
dayandı bakın buraları Biz yavaş yavaş
eşim ben çocuklarımla birlikte bu
ilerlemiyor galiba pardon biz bu hale
dönüştürmeye dönüştürdük burayı bugün 6
bin 500 metrekare kapalı alanı olan
içinde zeytinyağı Teknoloji Müzesi olan
çok modern Ege'de görebileceğiniz en
modern zeytinyağı fabrikası olan bilim
sanat tasarım merkezi olan Üst katında
sene yaşayacağımız sabun Temizlik hijyen
müzesi olan bir doktorunuzun hediye
etmesiyle antik çağda yeme içme
koleksiyon 388 tane parçayı bize hediye
etmiştim Onun yerini hazırlıyoruz çok
modern İso belgesi olan Hasip
kurallarını bir restoran ve buçuk Oteli
bu ile birlikte diğer yaratmaya çalıştık
ama insan her şey çocukluğundan giriyor
Arkadaşlar yani ben çocuklar bunları
hayal ettim Çünkü böyle bir toplumda ve
Yaşadım ve bu toplum beni buralara
getirdiği Buca'daki bu anlattığım olay
Bizimkiler Gülcemal vapuru ile geldiler
Buca yerleştiler ama beş 18tl bizim için
çok değerlidir çünkü bütün dedelerimizi
bütün bu canlıların hepsi tür
fabrikalarında çalışırdı 5.18 nedeniyle
akşamüstü Buca'ya gelirler Biz
istasyonda Onları karşıladık ve bütün
istasyon tütün kokar the 5 18tl bizim
için önemli zeytin de önemli Bağlar'da
önemli ama bu güzel yer yok edildi Tabii
ben Hayallerim Hep peşinden gittim çok
zor da olsa peşlerinde peşlerine kutu
değil onu tavsiye ediyorum yani
hayaliniz bırakmayın Yani biraz önce bir
dostunuz söyle ben ona katılmıyorum ne
dedi dedi geçmiş Çünkü dürüst rengi asla
bu geçmiş çok önemli bizim geleceğimizi
belirleyen şey Ben göremiyorum sizi
böyle daha iyi görüyorum aslında aslında
açmam lazım şöyle durayım geçmiş bizim
herşeyimiz Aslında biz geçmişimizle
geleceğimizi ışık tutan ve yol alan
insanlar geçmişimiz asla unutmayın
Hayallerinden asla vazgeçme her zaman
hayalkurun benim İbrahim kadar ilkokul
hocam bana Çocukluğumda ilkokul üçte
iken maket yapmayı öğretti Ben o gün
bugündür akşam bir şey yapalım İyi bir
akşam koyma acısıyım atölyem müzenin
içinde çok iyi bir atölyemiz var
hayallerimizin Hep peşinden gidiyorum
gitmeyede Çalışıyorum ama tabii müze
içinde bunları yaparken bakın bugün bu
hale getirdik Biz burayı Burada
gördüğünüz bütün tuğlaların hepsi 150
yıllık tuğlalar var ciddi Emek var mı
burada
da Slime Biz Çocukların eğitimine çok
ciddi katkı sağlamaya çalışıyoruz Bu
gördüğünüz Osmanlı işçiliği Biraz önce
bu kordofan işliği bu buradaki okula
destek vermek için yaptığımız bir olay
ve biz eğitim için sürekli Mesa bu bin
lira önce bir yıllık bir gemi çocukların
eğitimi için yaptık Burada gördüğünüz
bir alan çocukların çadırları için biz
eğitime sürekli destek veriyoruz 4
saniye kaldı artış dakikam var bu
eğitimden 30 tane mesela yakın zamanda
Suriyeli kadın açık kadınlar hak eden
çok eziliyor dünyada Buraya kendi
istediği gelmemiş bile olsa o kadınlar
Biz Suriyeli 30 tane kadına Kurslar ne
karısı verdik keçe kursu aldık ama bu
ülke Entegrasyonu okullarda projeler
yapmayı Fransız okulda projeler yapmaya
çalışıyoruz e mesela Erzurum'dan
bir tek ben ilçesinin Düzyurt Köyü nden
2820 kilometreyi rakımdan bir 12 tane
çocuğu getirdik buraya bu okulun
çocukları bütün Doğu Anadolu'da robot
konusunda şampiyon olmuş çocuklar bizi
çocukları bizim müzeye getirdik ve bu
müzede bu çocuklarla Cup yaptık bu
alanda yaptığı bunun için yapmıştık
zaten Burayı ve bu çocuklar bizim
Ege'den de bizim İzmir'den de 12 tane
gözükebilir RGB uzaktan izledim bunları
ilk günlerde bunlar ilk gün ayrı
oynadılar iki gün biraz konuşun Düzgün
artık sarmaş dolaş var oldular 3. biz
bunları matematik felsefe sanat kültür
bütün dersleri Bir hafta boyunca vermeye
çalıştık ve bunun sonunda çocukları
günde Gülbahçe denize götürdük
sorumluluk altı tane kız öğrenci altı
tane erkek öğrenci bunları bir denize
sokacaksınız ama bir sorumluluk yani
denize sokuyorsunuz öğretmenler varmış
üç tane öğretmen
Ya ben söylemesi Gülbahçe oraya koydum
ve bu çocuklar Zekiye bol su üstünde bir
aslandı Orada görmüş ve Bana Yazmış Bunu
ben de gözlerim yaşararak okudum ve bu
çocuklar deniz kıyısına geldiklerinde bu
Doğu Anadolu'dan gelen Çocuklar
özellikle kız çocukları Denizi kez
görmüşler hepsi 13 yüzden ilk kez
görüyor ve koşarak elbiselerle birlikte
denize dalmışlar ve çıkmışlar bireysel
olarak ağlamaya başlamıştı bütün
bizdekiler ağlamaya başlamış para
soruyorlar Sen bu işleri Neden
yapıyorsun birader diye İşte ben bundan
yapmaya çalışıyorum Şu yüzüne çok insan
geliyor geziyor ve anlatıyorum ben
bakayım bizim müzede bize üzerinden
tarihi anlatıyoruz sanat anlatıyoruz
zeytinin faydalarını anlatıyoruz sağlığı
anlatıyoruz Akdeniz diyetini anlatıyoruz
Osmanlı'nın sanayisi çocukları var bizim
elimizde çıktıktan sonra bana şu
o anlar ne yapmam lazım size sorayım ya
birader Doktor bey ve ama para görmüşsün
buraya ha dediklerinde ve diyeceğimi
bilemiyorum artık size bırakıyorum
bu slakten gönderemiyorum Evet bu bizim
bakın modern zeytinyağı fabrikamız Bu da
bulabiliyorsun zeytinyağının kadın
topraklarından bir tanesi bu ağaç Milat
4100 yaşları civarında ortalama yerden
bir buçuk metre yükseklikte gövdesinin
çapı 13 metre bir ucundan bir oca 21
metre 4100 yaşında ve burada bu ağaç
için bir şey yapmaya değmez mi değer Ben
de bunun için yaptım Çok teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]